hello everyone and welcome to a very
intense final round of the 2018 ulti box
Norway championship we have a game
between Sergei curtain and the
vishwanatham Ahmad and before we check
out the game let's just check out the
standings after round 8 so as you all
remember cousin Wesley so Nakamura and
Fabiano Caruana were in the lead for
points all of them then follows a chakra
moment they are 11 our onion which one
Alan the circuit hurricane and Maxime
holograph
so Corrigan who is playing this game
it's currently three points out of seven
and he's facing the Vishwanath on Anand
who is three and a half points out of
seven so if if Corrigan wins he doesn't
really have any chances of winning this
tournament body found wins this game and
then he joins well not joins but he
transcends the leaders with four and a
half points and if no one from the
leaders wins their games then there will
be a very nice playoff between a lot of
players but we're gonna talk about the
result somewhere after we show you the
game after I show you the game regarding
the last videos photo challenge of
course the players were short Karpov
Kasparov tall and so Sanko and for this
video I prepared also not too difficult
but very soon the photo challenges will
become very difficult so here it is best
of luck to all of you let's let's go so
who is this I believe he's having
probably 13 at the time this photo was
taken you all know him you know he you
know was it was a world champion at one
point for a for a very long time but
that's all of the hints that I will give
out so best of luck to you now let's
check out the game there is already a d4
on the board so ok car can plays d4 nice
to a6 c4 e6 and Knight to f3 and d5 yet
again we transpose into the Queens
gambit declined Knight to c3 Bishop e7
Bishop to 1/4 castles we have III c5 and
D captures on c5 Bishop captures and
Queen to c2 so this is all pretty
standard everything was played before
Knight to c6 we
a three Queen to a5 and we have a
queenside castle here nice to e4 and now
comes Knight to b5 so already a lot of
complications on the board and we have a
six allowing night to c7 so Kirk in does
plate we have a nice to see seven and
what do you do here the rook is under
attack and Allan plays d5 by playing a
five the bishop is no longer guarding
the knight on c7 so a Queen captures on
c7 is a threat so how do you prevent
this well Kirk and played rook captures
on d5 and now you have to decide what to
do here if you captured the rook then
you're gonna lose the bishop ended and
the knight will eventually be one so no
point giving in two pieces for the rook
but after rook captures on d5 you have
two options
ECAD persona 4 is an option and Queen
captures on c7 both of these moves will
turn out the same if Queen captures then
you get Queen captures on e4 e captures
on f4
look CalPERS on c5 f captors and III and
the Bishop to d3 threatening checkmate
before grabbing back the pawn this order
of moves was not played in the game in
the game instead of Queen captures first
phone captures Bishop on f4 was played
Queen captures on e4 now Queen captures
on c7 rook captures F captures on c3 III
and Bishop to d3 now again we reach the
exact same position where Kerrigan is
threatening checkmate on h7 so we have g
6f captures on e3 now and Bishop to e6
Queen to h4 preparing some a very nice
ideas like Queen to h6 and 9 g5 and a
nice checkmate on h7
so rook 88 and now Bishop to e4
immediately trying something with Knight
to g5 simply f6 the Queen will now be
guarding h7 and after captures captures
black will be fine here so after rook a
to e 8 bishops to e4 we have Queen to b6
attacking carbines rook on c5 and now
here Kirk in place Queen to h6 and now
there is a question can you capture the
rook
well if you did for example Queen
captures rook then of course you get
nice the g5 you were of course expecting
this and there there is really no good
way to prevent Queen captures on h7
checkmate the only thing you have
available as maybe a resources Queen
captures on e3 I have to remove the King
and now you have to play Queen captures
on g5 giving up the Queen and after
Queen captures yes you can even grab one
more pawn but the rock is at a
commercial unit for defending and you
don't you don't really have compensation
for the Queen for the Queen you have a
knight and a rook which is definitely
and the pawn okay but it's it's it's not
compensation enough so after Queen to h6
at first f5 attacking the bishop and
notice that the rook is still under
attack but you know this was all under
consideration
so Knight to g5 still threatening
checkmate and now up to f7 the whole
point of the f5 move making room for the
rook on f7 Bishop to d5 now again
offering a rook button Bishop captures
on d5 will be will be too much also and
Knight captures knife captors here a lot
of ideas possible so first before that
Bishop captures on d5 rook captures on
d5 and now Queen captures on e3 with
check King to be won and now rook F to e
7 with a nice rock rock Queen barrier
and on the e-file rook H to d1 and now
Queen to e2 and what do you do here here
a very much needed move is rook to d6
rook to d6 would prevent on an ins idea
that he will use in the next move and
will also you know exert a lot of
pressure to it's a blacks position here
h4 was actually played and on and
immediately takes care takes advantage
of this he plays Knight to e5 and 95 is
a deadly move 935 you're going for the
c4 pawn if you allow black to capture
the c4 pawn that's really really
uncomfortable for example if you
continue or attack h5 you know hoping to
win the game then Knight captures on c4
is coming and of course Queen to B 2
will be checkmate and there's really no
good way to stop this you have to give
up the rook but
Blackwell captured with check and after
you give up all the material there is
really nothing to do here you know you
can you could capture once but there's I
mean there's no way to break through
here so definitely not something you
want to do so another idea after Knight
to e5 and y h4 is such a such a terrible
move actually if you try and perhaps
defended the the c-4 point would be
three then you you see the idea Anand
had with this Knight to e5 move so you
know feel free to pause the video here
and find y h4 was was you know a pretty
bad idea there I will give it a couple
of seconds as usual a so for those of
you who found it congratulations you are
an excellent Queen Trapper and for those
who just won't enjoyed show of course
nice to G for simply tribe to the Queen
the queen is under attack there's no way
to go up on his guarding h5 you simply
lose the Queen and the game so after
Knight to e5 kurakin saw this and of
course he had to go back knife to f3 was
played but now comes Queen to e4 check
King moves and now Queen captures on C
for grabbing upon not only grabbing upon
but grabbing at with tempo so the white
king is in check so losing upon their
Kerrigan we have king - a1 and now comes
Knight back to G for attacking
Corrigan's Queen and basically forcing a
trade of Queens we have Queen to c1
Queen captures rook captures and King to
g7 and here after a car on 15 to g7 okay
you are down a pawn and you are playing
against the former world champion which
won a tournament so definitely not an
easy task but we've seen Sergey kirkin
who is also known as the Minister of
Defense you know to get out of worse
situations you know if you don't play
the absolute best moves you will not be
able to defeat him but here is a very
interesting move I will tell you what
happened in the next move Sergei
hurricane actually blunders another pawn
but I will ask you to do something
different here try to pause the video
here and try to figure out how exactly
car can wander the pond so it's a very
weird thing to ask of you but yeah still
you know if we figure out how pawns are
one
then maybe we can avoid doing it
accidentally in our own games so feel
free to pause the video here and you
know how how could have Sergey car cane
blundered upon well for those of you who
found it congratulations you are an
excellent point of tone blunderer and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show here h5 was played and now of
course Harkins idea was probably that of
course G captures on h5 is impossible ro
captures a knife f5 would come but here
on simply played Knight to f6 and it was
in this position that Segway car can
resign in the game the rook is under
attack
there is no good move for the rook here
simply when the rook moves and Knight
will capture the pawn it's simple as
that
and you know it's it's very hard for to
imagine for Carrick and to do something
like this this probably in this position
when he played h4 and allowed this
Knight to e5 idea by Anand this you know
this shook him so hard that when all of
this was said and done he completely you
know gave up on the game and just played
h5 like completely irrationally as he
was not in time trouble or anything like
that he just you know it's complete
complete blindness he just blundered one
point and naki blunders the second one
it's very hard to imagine for for a
player of Kirkenes you know ability and
endurance you know because hurricane
would you will usually have a really
really slow start to the tournament but
then you know he's really capable of you
know playing 18 rounds if needed
you know kurakin would definitely be a
fierceful candidate if he played in the
1959 candidates tournament however
everyone played four games against
everyone
but yeah nice to have six and here
Sergei car can resign the game so I
don't have the standings after this run
because one of the games is still being
played Fabiana Caruana versus wesley so
but as I've said before the video Anand
had three and a half half points before
the game now he has four and a half
points he joined a couple of other
players who have drawn their game but as
I will probably do at least one more
video on round
I just you know to keep you informed
we're gonna talk about the standings
after that so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Simon Babinec and the Jody Flint
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - my previous videos
here thank all for watching and I will
see you soon
most likely with another game from the
final round of the 2018 LT Box Norway
championship thank you all and I'll see
you soon